So, let's talk about an algorithm called SVM,
which is short for Support Vector Machines.
Why someone would call an algorithm as machine, I have no clue,
it was invented by a Russian, but it's a very popular algorithm.
At first approximation, what Support Vector Machines do is find a separating
line, or more generally called a hyperplane, between data of two classes.
So, suppose we have some data of two different classes.
Support Vector Machine is an algorithm that takes this data as an input, and
outputs a line that separates those classes, if possible.
Let me you give you three lines.
In each line is a little check mark.
Which line do you think separates the data?